my name is Keith words of these texts
Cheltenham Science Festival question
about dark matter and how we know it
exists they show you a map of the
universe the line the middle showing the
Milky Way our galaxy and then they say
AHA dark matter must admit I don't
follow the logic so how do we know
there's dark matter yeah hi Keith how do
we know that Dark Matter exists well
astronomers have many ways of detecting
and deducing the existence of dark
matter the original one dudu Vicky a
long time ago was that the motion of
galaxies in clusters of galaxies that
are held together gravitationally seemed
to move with velocities which were
greater than those that you could
explain just assuming that these
clusters were made out of just the
visible galaxies and nothing else and
being attracted by gravity he suspected
that there was some missing form of
matter that one couldn't see that with
holding these galaxies in place later a
astronomer called Vera Rubin did
measurements of stars and galaxies
rotating around the center of the galaxy
and noticed that their velocities were
much higher than those that would have
been predicted by Newton's laws if the
only mass in the galaxy were made up of
the visible stars so that led people to
conclude that there must be some form of
matter that we can't see that does not
radiate light that exists in the middle
of galaxies
and in the middle of these clusters of
galaxies holding them in place and
making them move fast but there's been
other forms of evidence which are
perhaps more convincing and the recent
years one being a wonderful picture of
two clusters of galaxies colliding and
after the collision it seems that the
ordinary matter and the dark matter that
forms a halo normally around the stars
around the whole galaxy have separated a
bit and their individual components can
be measured you can see the ordinary
matter directly because it radiates
light and we see it in our telescopes
the dark matter can be seen as well not
directly it's dark but indirectly
because any form of matter as Einstein
showed will serve as a gravitational
lens light coming from behind that dark
matter will be deflected and bent by the
dark matter and by this lensing effect
one can determine the distribution of
the matter that makes up the lens so in
this event the two forms of matter that
make up the galaxy have separated a bit
the ordinary matter which interacts
quite strongly more strongly with itself
undergoes some kind of friction and lags
behind and the dark matter has separated
and is seen in a slightly different
place it's a very dramatic picture and
finally the cosmological observation
many cosmological observations have led
to a rather good model of the history of
the universe from the Big Bang until
today and in particular the distribution
of cosmic microwave background depends
critically on the evolution of the
universe from the Big Bang 400
and years to when the cosmic microwave
background radiation was liberated and
which we measured today the agreement of
those measurements with a cosmological
model determines the matter-energy
content of the universe to a large
degree and the precise agreement that
has been achieved with the predictions
of those models requires that most of
the matter in the universe ninety
percent of the matter content of the
universe is in this form of dark matter
that's about just about the same number
that you get from these other
observations the motions of stars and
galaxies the motion of galaxies and
clusters and from events such as the
collision of Questers of galaxies so I
think it's quite conclusive evidence by
these indirect and via gravitational
lensing direct observation of dark
matter that it exists and pervades the
universal